haven't done one of these episodes in a
while
last time on shrew fear I talked about
the fight for independence or at least
the fight that happened to me and my
friend when we want to go see the
Independence Day movie that sucked where
some pretty creepy stuff ended up going
down so if you want to screen that
episode I'll leave a link and it's
really up to you if you want to watch it
though so my other creepy movie theater
story happened ten years ago when I went
to go see the movie
14:08 now I loved 14 away I think it's
one of the most underrated Stephen King
movies if you aren't familiar with the
film it's based off a short story about
an author who writes stories about
haunted places and someone challenges
him to stay in the supposedly haunted
hotel room in New York City he tries to
stay overnight in the room but soon
finds himself unable to distinguish
hallucinations from reality and unable
to escape room 1408 I want to go see
this with my two friends let's just call
them Billy and Bobby cuz those were
their actual names as I mentioned this
movie came out in 2007
so we were in seventh grade at the time
we just gotten to the age where we're
old enough to have our own cell phones
so my parents would drop me off at the
movies with my sanyo pcs vision phone
and I could call to get picked up
afterwards
that evening we had gotten to the
theater a bit late so we were just
walking in right as the movie was
starting about 30 minutes and or
something is the part of the movie where
the protagonist let's just call him Mike
Enslin because that's his actual name is
getting settled in the hotel when things
start to go weird now I know jump scares
tend to get a lot of hate these days but
I really like them when they're done
right and 14 away does an excellent job
of making the viewer put their guard
down before
so there are a bunch of jump scares in
this movie that involved the alarm clock
phone and other appliances around the
hotel room remember how I said that we
walked into the movie right as it was
starting well turns out that we missed
the silence earphones reminder and
Billie had forgotten the turn his phone
off before we sat down so sure enough at
the exact moment of the phone jump-scare
in the movie Billie's phone goes off at
a startling volume and I can't even
begin to describe the terror of that
moment the jump scare in the movie would
have been enough by itself the volume of
Billy's phone ringing in the movie
theater would have been enough by itself
but the fact that they happened at the
exact same time it made it feel for that
one moment like the haunts of the movie
were in the seats with us and this was
also before the days where there were a
lot of ringtone options so Billy just
had a generic analog phone ringtone that
almost matched the sound of the phone in
1408 it only took us a moment to figure
out what had happened but that one
moment was a moment of panic and it was
enough to put us on edge for the rest of
the 112 minute runtime there's not much
else to this story you can look at it as
a coincidence
so you can look at it as something
deeper but one thing you're definitely
gonna want to look at is the next
episode of true fear where cinder is
gonna be filling in and filling you in
on how a lunatic attacked her on the bus
so if you've got any scary stories about
the movies please do share them in the
comments we'd love to hear them if this
story has spooked you out of going to
the movies maybe you'd rather stay home
for some C's world and chill if that's
the case you gotta pick up this merch
I'll leave a link in the description
remember to subscribe to Suzy's world
for new Horrors every week ring that
death bell for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one assuming we
[Music]